I still remember vividly when I was
walking down the street with a Polish
friend of mine when all of a sudden she
told me Luka you don't say not Internet
you in this case you say stress internet
and that mistake that I had made and the
correction I gotten both stung for a
while
hi my name is Luca from Luca Lombardo
calm and today I'm going to talk about
how to deal with language mistakes I'm
pretty sure that if you've been learning
languages yourself this has happened to
you quite a few times you make a mistake
you get Corrections from whether it is
in a language class language exchange or
maybe a friend of yours just corrected
you while you were telling a story and
you were excited about it no matter
where who when how what matters is what
you do with that mistake how you respond
to it for example the first thing I
think that you should consider and take
into account is that if you made a
mistake
it means you tried it's better to try
something that not try something at all
because as they say if you don't try you
will never know so you should the first
thing is pat yourself on the back and
say I tried and I didn't miss out
imagine if you're trying to say
something in a language you always
resort to probably English you will not
have learned other things so that's the
very first thing to take into account
[Music]
there are simply two ways to see
mistakes as faders or as opportunities
if you see mistakes as faders you react
to them you focus you take you
personally you focus on the mistake that
you've made you don't listen and you
don't learn and you will probably make
that same mistake over and over again
instead if you have a positive a growth
mindset and you see mistakes as
opportunities you will probably focus on
the fact if you learn something and
everything will change as a consequence
of that you will remember that mistake
and you will not do it again you will
get enthusiastic because the next time
you will figure out oh I haven't made
that mistake again and this will fuel
your enthusiasm and your will to improve
more and more with time
another result another amazing
consequence of seeing mistakes as your
best friends is that you develop
self-awareness self-awareness is that
amazing thing in language learning that
allows you to create a mental space and
be able to observe yourself while you're
producing language or while you
listening to the language meaning you
can see gaps you can see patterns you
can notice things much more than you did
before again not only when you listen or
you read but when you yourself talk that
allows you to improve and ponder about
your mistakes or just the way you
formulate sentences the way you express
yourself and again that generates a lot
of enthusiasm and a very quick
self-improvement to conclude by
fostering courage you will act even when
it's difficult even when you're not sure
even when you're venturing into unknown
ground and you're not sure about the
outcome by nurturing gratitude you will
develop the capacity of learning and
appreciating everything from everyone in
any way even from people who by
correcting you want to hurt you and by
feeding self-awareness you developed a
mental space which allows you to keep
improving along old phases of language
learning overcoming the roadblocks that
are on the way so here you have it I
hope you liked the video if you want to
know more please click on the link in
the description box below and you will
be able to read and listen to a great
hopefully great and useful article that
I've put together for you once again
thanks a bunch for listening and talk to
you very very soon on this very same
Channel
[Music]